get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
every week we pick a few of our writers
from the issue
and get them to read out their pieces to
you this week we're going to be joined
by editor of the spectator's u.s edition
freddie gray
who writes about who the real joe biden
is
and then it will be joined by douglas
murray who talks about this new world in
which
allegations are made that can't be
proved or disproved
and at the very end katie balls our
deputy political editor
talks about the government's fears of a
second wave
first up it's freddie gray it is usually
a bad idea for a presidential candidate
to leave himself open to the accusation
that he is soft on law and order yet
last weekend joseph robinette biden jr
did exactly that
he attacked the egregious tactics of the
federal officers trying to control the
apparently never-ending riots in
portland oregon
sensing an open goal president trump's
campaign promptly accused biden of
siding with the criminals in any normal
election year such an exchange would be
a major flash point
in the covid19 riddled anarchy cauldron
that is america in 2020
nobody much cares joe biden can say
pretty much anything
or nothing at all and his lead in the
polls just grows and grows
there's now fewer than 100 days until
the presidential election
america's cities are still burning and
the 77 year old chandra who has no idea
what he is saying
is thrashing the 74 year old president
who has no idea what he is saying
the chinese must be quaking team trump
are quick to insist that as november
draws closer
and vocaters begin to focus on the still
presumptive democratic nominee
the dynamics of the race will shift in
their favor
biden has kept a low profile in large
part thanks to the pandemic
as the median scrutiny intensifies his
weaknesses as a candidate will become
too glaring
his incipient dementia too
embarrassingly obvious
the trouble is the trumpies have been
saying that for months now
and biden just keeps plodding ahead it's
increasingly clear that trump doesn't
know how to grapple with doddy old joe
the president is flailing
in an effort to peel off a few black
voters his talking heads are saying that
biden is racist because he gave a eulogy
for the infamous dixiecrat senator
stormtermand
and made some unpc remarks in the 1990s
at the same time they say he'd be the
most hopelessly woke commander in chief
it's hard to square these differing
images
the trump campaign has for now
apparently given up on targeting joe
directly
the president and his spinners are going
after the more left-wing democratic
governors and mayors
who have shut down their states and
cities in response to the pandemic
while pandering to the protester mobs
that's an admission of defeat
biden has been called a teflon candidate
but that doesn't quite do justice to his
slipperiness
he's almost sphinx-like his low
visibility
campaigns means he can represent
different things to different americans
to working class whites he's regular joe
the irish catholic boy from scranton
pennsylvania
to black voters he's barack obama's
loyal vice president
who's always had that tintonian knack of
sounding empathetic
to suburban women he's the eldest
statesman who will bring back decorum to
the oval office
to former republicans and independents
he's not donald trump
to tantrum throwing revolutionaries he's
a pushover in waiting
biden's campaign logo features his
famous aviator sunglasses
and what could be more american but
those reflective shades are also quite a
good metaphor for biden's candidacy
you see what you want biden's
legislative priorities are similarly
elusive
his campaign is adept at sounding
radical without committing to anything
controversial
this month he has promised to rip the
roots of systemic racism out of this
country
and transform this country exactly how
he doesn't say
on his website the joe's vision section
features more than 40 plans or agendas
these include the biden plan for climate
change the biden plan to end violence
against women
and joe biden's agenda for the catholic
community
it's all very repetitive joe biden will
ensure everyone is treated with dignity
no matter their race gender sexual
orientation religion or disability
team joe declares on every page after 15
minutes reading this platitude in astros
i searched in vain for joe's plan for
the board senseless
inclusivity has its limits
the worry among conservatives and
moderates is that president biden would
be a trojan halls for the hard left
he's so old that it seems unlikely he
will be able to preside fully over one
term
let alone too biden has already invited
congresswoman alexandre ocasio-cortez
the 30-year-old starlet of american
progressivism
to help formulate his policies would he
let the young radicals take charge
probably not a quick look at the front
ranks of the democratic party offers
proof as to how tightly the gerontocracy
grips its power in the house of
representatives the
speaker is nancy pelosi aged 80.
the majority leader steny hoyer is 81
and the majority whip and key biden ally
jim clyburn
is 80. retail politics is their modus
operandi
revolution is not
in the coming days biden will announce
his vice presidential nominee
which given his infirmity could prove a
momentous decision
he may well be picking the next
commander in chief
he has promised that he will choose a
woman and the indications are that it
will be a black woman
kamila harris val demings karen bass and
susan rice are considered favorites
biden may gamble on an outsider as did
his late friend john mccain
the republican nominee in 2008 in
choosing sarah palin
the mother of five governor of alaska
considering his
big lead in the polls it seems more
likely that biden will plump for a do no
harm running mate
somebody who ticks the identity boxes
but doesn't upset the wrinkled hierarchy
what is certain is that biden is willing
to spend vast amounts of federal money
the trump administration has already
thrown 6 trillion at the covert 19
crisis
biden wants much more whatever it takes
he says
he also proposes to increase government
healthcare spending dramatically
and his answer to racism is more tax
credits for black small business owners
plus 100 billion fund for affordable
housing for african americans
some observers are concerned about
biden's head for figures
he recently claimed that america had
over 120 million dead from covid
in a debate earlier this year he said
150 million americans have been killed
by gun crime never mind
it's only joe he won't be doing the sums
progressives are growing excited the
possibility that biden might surprise
everyone by becoming the next franklin
delano roosevelt
that is he'll put america back to work
after the ravages of kovid
in the way that fdr rebuilt the us
economy after the great depression
biden is indeed mooting a green new deal
to save america and as luck would have
it the planet at the same time
but obama who also came to power in a
crisis
promised much the same 12 years ago and
left america in the world disappointed
the only hope that biden will do better
is curiously
the lack of hope he brings he is in no
way burdened by the great expectations
that accompanied the arrival of the
first african-american president in
2009.
biden offers at best a dim memory of the
optimism that obama inspired
as well as the prospect of relative calm
after four turbulent years of trump
his election will be the democratic
equivalent of a giant sigh
biden's greatest strength is that unlike
trump he's widely held to be a good man
he has suffered in 1972 he lost his wife
and daughter in a car crash
and in 2015 his son bowed to brain
cancer
americans admire nothing more than
triumph over adversity and joe is
arguably at his best when talking about
grief
his ability to emote helps blunt the
other trumpian attack line
the biden is corrupt as vice president
he appears to have helped his other son
hunter
make highly lucrative deals in china and
ukraine
joe was also apparently complicit in the
shady attempt to thwart
trump's presidency by using the fbi to
spy on his campaign
for some reason nobody wants to believe
that the affable old boy is guilty of
such crimes
yet one of the reasons the obama biden
administration ended in the ascension of
trump
was that americans were sick of the
vinality in washington
the swamp that gets rich selling out
america's interests
it's hard to imagine that biden who used
to be known as the senator from mbna
because of his lobbying efforts
on behalf of the credit card industry
would lead an altogether pure
administration
it's worth noting that the chinese
parent company of tick tock
the social media app which trump's
secretary of state mike pompeo has
suggested should be banned on national
security grounds
has hired key democratic operatives with
links to biden
ahead of the november election the biden
campaign this week forced staffers to
delete tiktok from their phones
the democrats know that they cannot
afford to let trump make them look weak
on china
which thanks in no small part to covet
is now clearly established in the minds
of voters as foreign adversary number
one
the bottom line is that trump is being
played by beijing
it's difficult however to deny biden's
record of accommodating china as vice
president under obama
a president biden would be more
internationalist in outlook than trump
has been
that would make him more likely to take
military action than trump who for all
his apparent hot-headedness
should be given credit for not having
started a new war
biden by contrast has supported just
about every foreign intervention america
is embarked upon
in the past 30 years for him
restoring the soul of america may well
mean bombing somewhere to bits
he would also look to revive the
multilateral trade agreements that trump
so rudely junked
at first blush biden's victory might
seem bad news for brexit britain
since trump has always made such
positive noises about our departure from
the european union
but brexiteers have become pessimistic
about achieving the beautiful beautiful
u.s
uk trade deal that trump has long
promised
there is now growing excitement that
under biden the united states and the
united kingdom might join the
trans-pacific partnership
now renamed the comprehensive and
progressive agreement for trans-pacific
partnership
to form the world's greatest trading
bloc besides
the political class only likes dealing
with the political class
and most tory mps would be happier
working with biden appointees than the
wild characters from the trump
administration
under biden and boris the bonds of the
obama and cameramen administrations
might be re-established
both countries can happily go back to
hawking their interests to beijing
the civil unrest in america will abate
at least temporarily
and everybody will forget about those
chaotic years when donald trump was in
charge
keep on rocking in the free world that
was freddie gray
and now douglas murray the case of
johnny depp versus
the sun heard over recent weeks at the
high court in london
certainly gives fresh life to the old
warnings about dirty linen and its
public laundering
whatever the results i would be
surprised if it didn't provoke others to
think again
about the wisdom of reverting to the law
the influences
formerly known as the sussexes for
instance must be
wondering whether their forthcoming
legal case will result in them
solely being showered with praise
of course one has sympathy for famous
people who feel that they have been
badly portrayed
it is unpleasant to read nasty things
about yourselves in the newspapers
especially if you have spent years
reading largely pleasant things
carefully placed there by yourself or
your pr
team still the urge should be
resisted and almost all precedent
even before the depth trial shows why
unless you have been falsely accused of
a crime such as murder
taking legal action is always like
stepping in quicksand
the absence of this realization is one
reason why the young and unworldly
imagine that the courts are a good place
to settle their complaints
the misunderstanding comes from lack of
experience lack of knowledge of how much
can go wrong
and a zero understanding of the fact
that even exoneration
leaves some residue of the thing of
which you were accused
earlier this decade during one of their
frequent leadership contests
a man called john reese evans stood to
be that week's ukip leader
several years before he had made a joke
about a gay donkey trying to rape his
horse
the joke was not golden and the
candidate apologized when it resurfaced
yet he could not shake it from his
person
headline writers consistently scorned
the opportunity to describe his policies
foreign or domestic instead he was only
ever introduced with a scrabble entry
variously involving the words gay rape
man donkey horse and ukeb
as word slates go the one associated
with him was particularly sub-optimal
of course rhys evans could have sued but
had he done so the words most associated
with his name
would not have been magically
disassociated from it
more likely it would have embedded the
existing word association
this is a version of the conundrum that
must run
through every would-be plaintiff's head
our own time brings an added complexity
which is that
while being erroneously accused of rape
or murder allows you to prove your
innocence
the most damaging things of which a
person can be accused today
can in most cases be neither proved
nor disproved consider the most
damaging contemporary charge of all that
of racism when it comes to this
allegation
there is no agreed upon definition no
definitive means for it to be disproved
and no punishment for its false leveling
many cultural oddities of our time can
be traced back to this
curious yet rarely reflected upon fact
i recently got a little reminder of this
when a lecturer in post-colonial
literature at cambridge university
called priyamvada gopal tweeted out the
phrase
white lives don't matter
a number of people were unthrilled by
this statement
and made their views known naturally
gopal immediately went about accusing
all her critics including me
of being racists she then spent her
weekend
firing out late-night threats claiming
that lawyers letters would be imminently
wending their way in my direction
as towards all her other detractors
at this point twitter promptly revealed
even more unpleasant tweets
sent out by gopal over recent years
these included her claim last year that
she struggles
every day to resist her urges to kneecap
white men in the wake of this
controversy
gopal strangely made her twitter account
protected
so that no unapproved people could read
her ravings
and cambridge promoted her to a full
professorship
to date i have still received no
communication from professor gopal's
lawyers
and i suspect that this is for the same
reason that her pigeonhole
has remained unbothered by any
communications from mine
for while i presume that both professor
gopal and i could try to sue each other
it would be in neither party's interests
to do so
if she wished to try to prove that my
distaste for her style of communication
is based solely and knowingly on a
dislike of her racial origin
then i suppose she would have to prove
that there is no
other reason to criticize her and
if i chose to argue in court that i was
a victim of racial discrimination at the
hands of professor gopal
then i suppose i would have to rely on
getting a jury subtle enough to
recognize
that a victim of racism might be a white
writer
as much as it might be a non-white
academic
none of this personally bothers me over
much because i still have the
opportunity to explain myself in public
and say what i actually think to the
best of my ability
what does worry me is the fact that most
people
can have no hope of such recourse
now that the bookshops have reopened i
have wandered around a couple
depressed to see them piled high almost
exclusively
with books scolding customers for their
alleged racism
i can think of a fair few things i would
like to say about this
but what would i dare say if i was just
another customer
rather than a customer and an author
with outlets
the words bookshop rant and racist
are just waiting to be used against
anybody who makes any criticism of this
latest hectoring
and once attached there would be no way
to remove the stain
the public would not care employers
would be unlikely to stand by the
accused
and if anyone even dreamt of going to
the law
they would have to raise vast sums of
money to try to disprove something
that would ignite a headline salad to
make john reese evans's one
look enviable i don't know what the way
out of this societal conundrum is
lawyers tell me that it requires
innocent plaintiffs
to make case law which is all very well
but the problem with legal precedence is
always the same
who would want to be the one to make
them
that was douglas murray and now katie
balls
as the government struggled on saturday
with the question of whether to impose a
quarantine on those returning from spain
there was a hold up a key minister was
unavailable
transport secretary grant shafts on a
holiday flight to spain
and hadn't landed yet when shapz
eventually made it onto the zoom call
from his holiday villa
one person who sat in on the meeting was
surprised by the speed at which the
quarantine decision was made
after being stung by accusations that
the government moved too slowly
in its initial handling of the pandemic
boris johnson now wants to show it it's
moving quickly
the spanish quarantine which is more
draconian than the approaches taken by
france or germany
shows the prime minister is prepared to
enforce heavy restrictions with little
warning
even if this means a backlash from
business leaders and his own mps
with a spike in recorded infections in
european countries such as belgium and
france
johnson this week warned that the signs
of a second wave of the pandemic are
here
but it's not the prospect of having to
extend the travel quarantine to other
tourist hot spots
that is giving the government great
cause for concern it's the fear that the
second wave could soon hit these shores
throughout the corona virus crisis the
government has been observing how other
countries have dealt with the pandemic
looking for clues about what to do and
what not the spike in infections in the
southern states of the us
was taken as a warning about opening up
too quickly
but now that germany which adopted a
more cautious approach about lifting
lockdown
and leads away in testing has also
reported an uptick
some worry that any substantial easing
risks a spike
the prime minister began the sum of
optimism and a desire to return to his
domestic agenda
but ministers report that in recent
weeks his concern has grown
over the prospect of a second spike
johnson has publicly
ungraded his optimism for the country
returning to normal
two weeks ago he said he hoped the last
remaining restrictions could be lifted
by november
now it's the middle of next year he has
warned business leaders that there will
be more to come
from the coronavirus crisis this year
the timing of a second wave is a huge
concern for whitehall
one figure involved in the pandemic
planning from the start
is recalling the early warnings about
the risks of too strict a lockdown
with a sense of dread chief scientific
officer patrick valance suggested in
march
that clamping down too hard could see
the virus return at the wrong time
a winter crisis and a second wave
together is almost unthinkable
a government advisor tells me
discussions are underway is how best to
avoid any surge in cases
the aim is to do all it takes to avoid a
second national lockdown
which is catastrophic by the government
there are two main reasons for this
firstly lockdown measures would be
harder to enforce in the winter
is one thing asking the elderly to queue
outside a supermarket in may
it's another and a cold night in
november a minister tells me
secondly in the words of one government
figure it would spell
economic armageddon
ministers have already started to
consider their arguments in the event
that some things have to close in order
for others to open
the schools or pub's dilemma as it is
known in whitehall
the public backlash over the failure to
get children back in the classroom
before summer
means there is a sense in government
that schools must be fully open in
september
even at the cost of closing other things
down
if schools aren't back our core voters
would not forgive us
once one minister however large amount
of social contact in iran's secondary
schools is a problem
in israel public health officials have
blamed the decision to reopen schools in
may
for july's spike in infections
the two tools at the government's
disposal to prevent a second national
closure
are test and trace and local lock down
in number 10
hope is being placed on an increase in
testing capacity
but with no contact tracing apps still
there is only so much good it can do
while polls suggest the public broadly
support johnson's whack-a-mole strategy
of local lockdowns
mps are skeptical about its long-term
popularity
it's like public support for tax risers
says one tory mp
people say they back them because they
don't think they'll be the ones paying
people support local lockdowns until
they are the ones in it
he may have a point neil o'brien mp for
harborough
in south leicestershire was initially
very supportive of the government
strategy
but that slowly changed as lester's
locked and dragged on for nearly a month
a government loyalist he has been
reduced to adding
let us out to his tweets a source of
frustration among those affected by
local lockdowns is that there are no
objective criteria of what triggers
or maintains local lockdown in a recent
meeting with a cross-party group of mps
the health secretary and dido harding
head of test and trace
were insistent that there could be no
one-size-fits-all set of guidelines
as there are too many factors to
consider however
without such clarity mps worry there
will be local anger about why an area
has been locked down
there is also a concern that there could
be community tensions
if whole towns have been shut when the
problem is only in certain neighborhoods
places currently in local lockdown still
have access to emergency economic relief
despite this local business owners can
feel as though they face a severe
disadvantage
it will be even worse when the photo
scheme ends predicts one mp
the treasury is reluctant to come up
with any general local lockdown relief
packages
on the grounds there is no way of
knowing how many times these measures
would be required
of course johnson's great hope remains
that the structures in place work
that more lockdown scenarios do not come
to pass and the virus remains under
control
but if this happens the uk would be an
outlier and success
after a difficult four months in which
britain has lagged behind other
countries
it is perhaps understandable that there
is not much optimism across government
that was katie balls thanks for
listening to this podcast
as ever do email us at podcast
spectator.co.uk
to give us your thoughts but what's even
better than that is if you rate and
review and subscribe to our podcast
wherever you get your podcast from
because that helps more people to
discover it
thanks for listening and join us again
next week
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher